[Applaudissements]
c'est vincent mannequinat l'air de rien
devinez qui m'a dit le nom envisage de
la mode internationale s'est pas mathieu
nous regarder c'est qui ce we mokhtar
notre johnny depp de la sécu est devenu
à mike hayes jerry d'une marque de
vêtement et maintenant il fait tout
comme un mannequin regarder il entre
dans une voiture comme un mannequin est
presque quoi tout est vrai il monte les
escaliers de chez lui comme une
mannequin sarney que le tapis en velours
boom
il boit des coups avec son pote comme un
mannequin on s'est même procuré les
premières images du prochain catalogue
regardez mon retard en chasseur sexy à
la campagne
voici les deux beaux gosses atouts du
vrai nom c'est la fin non pas ceux des
bus charte qu'on n'a pas mis les beaux
gosses un jouet l'année